[Laughter]
the avril lavigne song complicated
wouldn't it be great if you learned that
and sang that like did a little karaoke
with complicated is a little fu to mark
murphy and we see that on social media
that would be nice well that happens
hold on i just my i just lost a piece of
my brain did you how do you know avril
lavigne and complicated you don't know
me not listening to him
you know me
yeah i know you're pretty i have been
you don't look like the kind of guy
that's going down into the barn
listening to avril lavigne and singing
complicated
opening the show tomorrow florio dancing
to avalor
[Music]
uh yeah disturbing to say the least
um all right
that is that even the song are we gonna
have to pay somebody now is that the
song that didn't sound like i hope so i
hope it's you i hope you gotta pay
admiral levine like 500 000 that would
be awesome avril lavigne tell your
lawyers to to uh turn off the meter that
is not your song that is being infringed
upon on this program all right no
excuses for
2021 we had kicked this around as it
relates to quarterbacks we've mentioned
it as it relates to a few quarterbacks
this is broadened to anyone in the
league chris go ahead i'll give you the
first pick
who has no excuses for 2021 you know i'm
gonna go
i'm gonna go with daniel jones to lead
off this draft all right i know we've
talked about him a few times here
throughout you know this i'm a giants
fan of course they're always on my radar
but
i look at this as a year to go
hey the offensive line's in a pretty
good spot
it's you know year yeah we're in year
three right year three uh year three and
they got you know saquon back kenny
galladay you know darius slayton pretty
good i think there's enough talent here
it's another gear in the jason garrett
system to where i look at it and i'm not
sitting here i'm going to say i'm
blaming wins and losses and everything
on daniel jones but i expect to see
really solid consistent football play
from daniel jones there is no excuses
everything
is in a positive you know light or
anything like that on the giant's
offensive side of the ball and uh it's
on him a little bit this year there's no
doubt
i agree with you completely it's up or
out for daniel jones probably either
becomes what josh allen became or
something close to it now that may be a
little bit too much to expect but but we
want a similar jump and if he doesn't
iron out some of the flaws holding the
ball for too long etcetera i mean
they've invested money they've invested
draft picks in making the offense better
and saquon barkley's going to be back
he's going to be healthy no excuses for
daniel jones that would have been my
first pick as well i'm going to go with
sean mcvay and he's embracing the
heightened expectations he's heightening
the expectations by constantly praising
matthew stafford but this is a team that
got to the divisional round without
stafford
stafford's great staffordsis stafford's
that cam akers is going to be the new
workhorse tailback right they've got
that great defense with jalen ramsey and
aaron donald no excuses for this team
now you don't have to win the division
but you better be able to go on the road
in the playoffs and win
uh after you survive that that fight to
see who wins one of the best divisions
in football and this is a guy who got to
the super bowl in his second year
there's been some talk of burnout he
addressed that with albert breer
recently too he said i feel 30 again
sean you're 35. i hope you feel 30. i
mean it's been a hard four years if at
35 he feels like 30 is a major
difference so uh i i i just wonder
whether he's wound a little too tight
and i wonder how much time he really has
left before he goes and takes
broadcasting money but this year no
excuses to not at least get to the
divisional round if not to the nfc
championship game and maybe even back to
the super bowl yeah i mean no excuses to
the very fact of like we expect them to
be like a special offense i think that's
the one thing like it should be an
offense that's certainly towards the top
you know
dancing around the top five-ish i think
with that type of talent you're i'm with
you i i should be a great defense too
yeah should be a great defense too
they have invested in the picks they
have invested their big thing like we've
talked about is depth of the football
team you know they've been flirting with
danger they are very like hey are
starting 22 and then there's a major
drop off and that's the only thing i
worry about them and you know i i you
know mcvay stafford i think either one
you could have probably used for that
pick right there right and i was going
to use stafford next but since you did
mcvay i'm going to change and not do
that i think the next one i'm going to
have to go with here is
i'm going to go with sam darnold the
carolina panthers been a lot of talk
there and there is no excuses for him
this year either he's in a place that
got a pretty good system and unlike the
jets and where he was at where the jets
dropped the ball and lack of support
that excuse does not apply here with the
carolina panthers another team that's
kind of got their offensive line in
order but you got christian mccaffrey
you got robbie anderson who can fly and
you got dj moore who you know i have a
man crush on is this is a budding
superstar so i think you look at it like
that you know system
good protection run game
running back who's awesome in the past
game and two good receivers you know
there should be some positive results
from sam darnold this year not again
that we have to see pro bowl or all pro
or they got to be the number one seed
but we certainly should see a guy where
we go damn that looks a little bit more
like a top five pick in the draft a few
years ago
i am going to do next something that i
ridicule you for oh you're gonna pick a
whole organization
i am you're picking the browns aren't
you no okay i'm picking the titans
picking the titans okay but when they go
all in for julio jones no excuses this
year win the division make noise in the
postseason compete with the big boys in
the afc because you've got the
four-headed monster on offense ryan
tannehill derek henry aj brown julio
jones you made this big move your
defense is better you should be a high
level contender just two years removed
from being in the afc championship game
no excuses for the titans this year yeah
okay i i i i wrote down ryan tannehill
on my list you know a little bit for the
similar reasons of what you're talking
about there you're right that was a big
time move you're gonna have you know
higher expectations of your football
team for sure uh that's
i honestly
was thinking about doing the browns
organization but i'm not gonna just
because i don't want to do organization
back to back here but they are one where
i look at it like there's no excuses
like it should be playoffs and it should
be one playoff win
and maybe not maybe like that's that
should be like the low bar
for the way that team's set up right now
and the way it looks so that that but
i'm gonna pick instead
carson wentz
big year for carson wentz
um again not that we got to see mvp
but we need to see really good football
play there's a system there's a support
there's a supporting cast around him
with the cults it's one of the better
offensive lines in football we know they
got jonathan taylor can run the ball
yeah receivers maybe not superstars but
a lot of good that we talk about all the
time it's a very consistent well-rounded
group and we'll see if maybe a paris
campbell or somebody else jumps out but
you know i do think that he's a guy that
yeah he can't we can't play the angle of
the injury nick foles you know the
eagles were crappy and did a bad thing
and the jalen hurts that that's all out
the window you got to see positive stuff
from wence this year
and see i've assessed these choices from
the perspective of whether it's a player
getting in a better situation or a team
consciously making an upgrade it
eliminates excuses and that's why for me
the last one is going to be mike zimmer
the coach of the vikings because there
were excuses last year the excuses last
year were i didn't have the players on
defense i didn't have denial hunter we
didn't have fans for our home games that
was a legitimate excuse one of the best
home field advantages in all of sports
and you don't have it so
this year
they've got a better defense they've got
fans back their offense is better
you've got justin jefferson who's
already blossomed as one of the best
receivers in the nfl dalvin cook still
in his prime kirk cousins
in that system that they have managed to
keep even though gary kubiak retired his
son clint takes over no excuses for mike
zimmer this is a year that i i feel like
not that he would get fired if he gets
to the playoffs and doesn't win a game
or two but i feel like this is the year
when you look at the nfc that maybe it's
not unreasonable to expect him to win a
game or two in the postseason against
this field unless he comes up against
the buccaneers before uh you know the
championship round
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports